[Music]
foreign
[__] so stupid dude
I thought that
them being away from me was the best
thing for them
that my daughters not having their
father in their day in a day-to-day life
was what was best for them
because I was that [__] up got lost I
was that lost I don't need to be around
me and then there's this lie that we
tell ourselves
that
I'm holding everybody back in that
that if I wasn't here if I was gone
everybody'd be better off
and there's a dialogue and anybody
that's been in that dark spot knows that
there's that dialogue that's like I'm
actually the one holding everybody back
and I would be they would all be better
off
if I was just
gone and that's how you get to that day
at the beach yeah
can you yeah man I was just I saw that
and I was just I felt so lied to
I've got this
this family that I don't even recognize
um
and I was just so emotionally
exhausted
and when it comes to people commit
suicide I don't think people really want
to die I think they're so and they're in
so much pain and they're so exhausted
that they
they just want to rest man
they're just
they're just they just want to break
from the pain and they they're so
exhausted they just want it they just
wanted a break so they can just breathe
and then so what they you know what the
thought is like well I'm so tired and I
just can't handle this anymore I can't I
can't bear the the weight of what I feel
so I'm gonna make it a permanent
decision off a temporary problem
so like I
I grab the piece and I was like and that
was the concept is like my daughters are
going to be better off without me my
wife's gonna be better off without me
everybody's just going to be better off
without me they'll get their insurance
money and [__] life will just go on
and roses and they won't have to deal
with this like sad sack of [__] as a
father I'll be out of the picture she
can meet somebody new that's like
positive and happy and you know making
money and can take care of everybody
um I'll be out of there you know they're
young and I'll be out of the picture and
they'll be able to go on thrive
and I'll just [__] fade away
and they'll go on and live their life
and everything will be good
I'm the one I'm the problem for them I'm
holding them back
and so I go down there and with full
intention of just [__] Calling it
Quits
that's a [__] lie dude it's a lie
because while you do you know what it's
not even just a lie it's a [__]
chicken [__] it's a chicken it's a
cowardly [__] thing it's a selfish
coward thought and the reason why is
yeah your pain ends guess where it goes
it [__] transfers to them and
everybody that loves you
it goes all it does is it takes all of
your [__] pain and it puts it all on
your kids and all in your family and
your brothers and everybody who [__]
loves you it just transfers them it's
the most selfish thing anybody can
[__] do
instead of just [__] fixing it owning
it so I went down there with the
intention of doing that and I'm gonna
I'm you know I'm an aquatic person and
maybe he was destined to be that way I
don't [__] know I don't know how the
universe works but I went down there on
the beach and
I heard the waves crashing
and
I'm Barefoot in the sand so there's a
grounding aspect which I didn't realize
you know at this point in my life I
didn't realize about frequencies and
I've gotten real weird in my older age
but there's there's frequencies in the
world and there's frequencies in our
body and there's frequencies on the
Earth and so I'm Barefoot on the beach
so I'm getting grounded right I had no
phone on me so I had no technology on me
and I'm and I'm like I'm [__] pissed
I start screaming and uh
I don't know I just felt this like kind
of weight come off of me and I hear and
after I'm like basically I just can't
[__] scream anymore
I'm hearing this waves
and I just start calming down
I kind of Catch My Breath and I just sit
there
and I started thinking about my my girls
and what kind of life that they're gonna
have
let's [__] get back in the truck and
go home
and I remember like I remember the time
my wife looked him out like [__] like
her face was like pale as [__] I think
she knew
and uh
[__] stupid but I went in the kitchen
poured a glass of [__] [__] Scotch
a whiskey or something something brown
and sat down and started drinking
that was a [__]
that could that could have just
completely ruined my kid's lives
it was all [__] selfish all because
of my own pain
man you know you you know like you
you know I admire you for so many
reasons man and but like one one of the
things I'm like really
like taken with
it is like you know in the way that you
like tell your story
you know you don't make like there's a
there's an element
um of universality to it that you you
you you you like keep going into that's
based on what I feel is like a real love
for people like you're not saying hey
this is
this is anybody who's going through
something yeah it's not anybody it's not
chest beating that's right it's not like
hey I was like this Warrior and it's
because you're like no man it's like my
whole life like I you know it's like our
whole lives like we'll be in these
situations but like this is kind of what
this is what I did this is what I feel
like we all need to do and again there's
this element I think that's like you're
trying to put this out there for your
kids and for everybody everybody thinks
that they're a special [__] butterfly
you're not dude like we're all going
through the same [__] we're just not
talking about it yeah you think that
your pain is your pain no dude everybody
it doesn't matter what community come
from like we're all dealing with the
same stuff and if you're not [__]
talking about it we're not like it's the
best way to connect with something you
really want to like you really want to
connect with somebody like yo man this
is the [__] that I've been through is
the pain up dude I've been through that
like it was a different thing but like
that that's how you can find that
connection and that thing about we're on
this side or we're on this side it's
like dude you know we've all the way
that you you kind of break it down that
I'm so taken with is you talk about this
like extreme
necessity of of being like deeply
vulnerable yeah but also
also you never lose sight of the the
voice in your head that says [__] get
your [__] together [__] and it's
like those two things you can be both of
those things you can be hugely
empathetic hugely vulnerable hugely like
take care you can be the warrior in the
garden that's right you could be the
warrior in the garden can you walk us
through that a little bit yeah it's like
that old I think it's Sun Zeus like it's
better to be a a warrior in the garden
than a gardener at War there you go like
[__] do you find yourself you're a
gardener and you're at War you're [__]
up you've definitely misstepped you know
what I'm saying you know I want to be
you know I every man should be a warrior
should be a [__] monster every man
I'm not talking about like [__]
special operations and I get [__]
that [__] out of your head if you're a
man you should be a [__] Warrior can
you tell me what that means to you
you need to be in control of your body
if you're fat get on fat
get fit set the [__] example for
those around you your kids are watching
you your kids are watching you
do you think it's possible to be like
emotionally uh emotionally healthy when
you're physically not absolutely it's
all one package I do this thing I have
this thing called the success Matrix you
can't be you can't be broken super fit
that doesn't work you can't be super
wealthy and have [__] relationships
right it's all one piece I I go back to
that special operations model like
everything has to overlap in this bubble
for for us to be successful
my finances have to be on point my
fitness has to be on point my self-doubt
and self-belief has to be my faith has
to be on point and my relationship has
to be on point that's a successful man
but admit like you have to go be a
warrior
like you need to be able to control your
own body like you you've been into
martial arts you got your kid in jiu
jitsu
like you grab if I go grab some random
man
let me grab I grab one of these guys
they're gonna get really uncomfortable
yeah if I grab you yeah you're not
uncomfortable yeah yeah you know what I
mean yeah you get in somebody's bubble
yeah they [__] freak out man yep
that's I mean a huge reason why we have
a lot of the problems that we have
they're not people they're not
comfortable and they're walking around
with this [__] fear constantly of
like I don't want like dude just just go
try it a few times and you'll see like
you do it for like six months and it may
it amazes me the confidence that it
brings to somebody a man's life but but
think about that as a leader right as a
as a leader in your house like how are
you gonna teach your kids yeah how are
you you got you have to make them
comfortable in their own skin
but what does that do like most Fighters
do they fight on the street no dude
no bro yeah yeah that's just dangerous
yeah you'll get [__] hurt or in
trouble or in trouble for what yeah yeah
you know what I mean that's the reason
why so it's it's and then what do you do
you're you put that on your kids as well
but what does that do mentally for you
it can you now you learn how to control
your emotions
you know how to be like Jordan Peter
says best you need to you need to become
an absolute monster and learn how to
control it
foreign
[Music]